[Music]
[Music]
this week
not even week part two
of our candid
conversation with star author of
longshot how political nobodies took
andrew yang national the new playbook
that let us build a movement zach
grauman and for those of you who are
tuning in just now you should know that
part one of this conversation uh is the
previous episode so check that out but
because
this book is so awesome this deserved a
double episode and we are
starting this convo just around when
my presidential campaign starts to get
its legs under it and that was the
beginning of 2019 zack what do you
remember about the beginning of 2019 we
had known so first thing i'll say we i
got a lot of compliments on the first
episode the first part of this so thanks
guys sounds like we are going back
remember down memory lane a bit
but um to answer your question
we knew we were getting on rogan
a little before new year's right i don't
know what we found out like right around
oh snap you're right so i go on rogan
like second week of february 2019
and i find out about it maybe like six
weeks ahead of time yeah so right in the
middle of january it was like because we
were trying to find out
so we just got we'd gone sam harris like
seven months ago or so and that was a
good boon for us we're like so what
other
sam harris's are there there's a plan
and the big the takeaway was like it's
kind of just joe rogan and a couple of
epic pods
uh
we found out we're going on joe and
we're like hell yeah and then we
basically
spent to zero
uh it is really funny where we were so
confident
that
i don't even want to say i would
catalyze
the campaign
that we just spent like the money was
going to come in after it was wild in
the sense that uh
i think you're you were right you talked
about this in the last episode like you
know
if joe rogan doesn't do it this
campaign's probably
gonna die um probably um
and
it's not worth splitting hairs over ten
thousand dollars whatever we're talking
about but um we basically stopped doing
the traditional fundraising events and
we hoped that joe rogan would basically
like 10x sam harris and give us a
healthy runway
and uh
that's my memory in january and it was
um
we had kind of built the yang gang then
um
in terms of locking things down we were
uh but we weren't really making any
hires we didn't have any money we
weren't growing um
so
i'm trying to think what what january it
wasn't a slow month but it was what did
they announce the requirements for the
june debates so this is where we lucked
out i think it was february 12th joe
rogan happened
and two days later they announced the
requirements for the debate this is
where we got some luck our way finally
so here's something that has never
before been revealed i think i don't
know so um joe rogan's a big deal but
we're busy leading up to it so i'm in a
rental vehicle between towns and uh iowa
in early
2019 it's winter
and i'm like hey guys like let's just
play some joe rogan episode so i have
like a sense of oh that's right so we
went to iowa a couple times in january
or iowa new hampshire yeah yeah
and
there was one conversation he had with
sam harris which was very helpful
when i realized that sam harris had been
deeply concerned about ai
before i came along um and said to joe
it's like look someone has to try and
prepare our society for ai and so when
he saw me running for president sam
harris he was like hey
this guy might help prepare us for ai
like let me try and help him right
and sam was also the person who called
joe rogan by the way and was like hey
joe have gang yeah that was the genesis
there yeah yeah so
so after i listened to that conversation
between joe and sam harris i was like oh
my gosh like sam harris has been
uh kind of waiting for someone like me
or paving the road and now that i'm here
he's trying to pave the road further and
that led me to joe
but
hearing these conversations uh actually
really invigorated me because i was like
i am
what
this
uh certainly what sam was was waiting on
and i thought to some extent what joe
was waiting on um and so
my
uh excitement level for it just going
kept going up and up uh leading to the
day of yeah
and we had hope so we raised a good
chunk of change from
you know basically people listen to
podcasts and they donate and um
so we were hoping that joe rogan
probably has a 10x the size of sam's
audience or so and so we're hoping to
10x the donations and
joe was
i think he was hesitant because other
people i mean he had a lot of fans that
asked him to come on and stuff i think
he was a little hesitant on ubi you had
to sell him on it
but
so you go we go to la
um
i remember
like driving around la getting like a
smoothie
like making sure i was like it was joke
we always called the candidate the baby
like make sure the baby got some sleep
last night like babies well-fed so i'd
make sure it fed the baby
uh before he had the big performance um
and
but i'm trying to remember i'm so
basically joe has this like hanger
the man hanger man hanger it's pretty
cool and if you're with the guest you
sit in this like kind of waiting room
and you can watch it live on the screen
it's pretty cool definitely the coolest
podcast setup we've ever been to um
and
i'm sitting in there with one of his
friends or something and someone we
brought along over and i'm watching the
thing and
joe pressed you on something like real
hard
and
if i watched the episode i remember what
it was but he pressed you on something
and like my heart dropped i was like oh
[ __ ] did yang you were talking about
i think it was something to do with some
part of job displacement whatever it was
and joe like double question double down
i was like no no no what about this and
i my heart dropped i was like oh [ __ ]
gang like please tell me you've done
your research and then you doubled down
and pressed him back and was like oh
yeah yeah it came out so i knew his [ __ ]
and then i was like oh god this is gonna
go well because joe did a really good
job asking a lot of like the tough
questions on universal basic income in
your platform um
so yeah it went pretty great and we
raised a bunch of money real quick
yeah it felt so one of the things that
happened in the campaign this was not
always the case but the joe rogan
definitely was the case
where
uh i kind of felt like the moment was
important and was very very present
i mean if you can imagine me running for
president
i had some weird interview
all the time every day maybe like you
know four or five a day if you include
events maybe you know like you know five
or six
um and so it's not like i'm like you
know 100 on each one of them i mean
you're you know it like it's impossible
to operate like that but the joe rogan
thing that it felt historic to me when i
went in there the same thing happened
actually when i sat down with sam harris
seven months earlier i sensed i was like
this is going to be really really
important yeah
and i'm not even sure if that process
through which my
thinking something is important was
uh
rational or conscious it's almost like
you feel
like you feel this energy around it
you're just like oh
um now i i say this that this didn't
happen every single time because there
were times when frankly i didn't think
something was important that it turned
out to be
true more about that
but there were times when it lined up
and certainly that was one of them and i
got to say the impact was immediate
like i would walk around
yes the next
week and all of a sudden my
recognizability shot up and i will say
this to you all that if you are the
candidate
you can sense the energy around you all
the time
uh and the energy around me just shot up
where if i just went into a random
restaurant someone would just look at me
and say like hey like nice job on rogan
yeah like things that were not happening
at any time previously yes actually
before that someone would come up to me
sometimes and be like hey
like i heard you on sam harris i'm a big
fan that's where and i wrote about this
in the book people joe rogan this is i
don't know is post spotify numbers
because it's behind a wall now and
there's not a lot of data you can get
but uh
pre-spotify let's say um
joe rogan was
game of
thrones sunday night hbo prime time
every time he touched a mic
if not double or triple that certain
episodes uh we're talking tens tens of
millions of people watching his stuff
every episode not just at youtube and
audio
um
it's a joke when the mainstream media
would call him fringe or i mean he's
like he's like you could take tucker
carlson
uh
chris cuomo
r.i.p
in terms of that show uh
and uh rachel maddow
combined them and you wouldn't reach joe
rogan you wouldn't combine to joe
brogan's uh reach and
we were um
we knew this we didn't but we didn't
know like what that actually meant in
terms of practice so what happened was
we remember just refreshing it we're
like
i think we raised 250 grand in a week
and just kept going um
but we lucked out i mean we went to
in-n-out after which was great to
celebrate um because we're like raising
now frank we have money now um
but
the dnc shortly after this this was our
biggest stroke of luck shortly after
like literally in the heated joe like
the height of the joe rogan like hype
train
was
they announced that the debate
requirements were to either get one
percent
in three polls
um that they had approved or 65. or 65
000 individual donors
uh and so like all the joe rogan hype we
were able to just like funnel
into oh you like the guy donate a buck
um
and so
we did it in a month it was essentially
exactly one month from
joe rogan's appearance and it was in the
announcement they announced and it was
wild so and now give so i wrote by the
book sam stein
who was a reporter at the daily beast um
he's savvy i like him because he was
tracking and he's like i've been we we
had a we one of the things we did really
well is we measured real well so we had
a progress bar on the website so if you
donated we could track and the fans were
the yang gang was refreshing that every
day you can see little andrew move
across the screen
but you'd have uh he calls it like i've
been tracking you guys and it looks like
you're gonna hit
65 000 donors any day now like i want
that story um
and
it's true and the names were like it was
this list it was
joe biden bernie sanders elizabeth
warren pete boudej kamal harris
and your [ __ ] gang and we were still
a nobody so it was wild to see like oh
my gosh this is real it's very real um
and now that everyone else is calling us
an internet troll or that's our thing
but we knew at that point we knew like
this is real this is gonna be real and
then after we hit the 65 000 we were
like hey they're going to raise the
threshold and what was the next number
they had uh 120. it basically doubled we
we doubled it essentially we boosted to
100 i think before the first debate yeah
and and then we were like oh well we can
hit that next number
yeah actually they didn't i think they
moved it to 90 and then 100 120 they
kept moving it up i don't think they
exactly doubled every time
it eventually got a 200 000 or so 180
something like that i don't remember off
top my head
um
so
it was great because we gave the yang
gang a very
tactical way to support
um
because you know getting people
registered vote hard like donating a
dollar getting 10 people to donate a
dollar like you could you could get 100
people to donate a dollar to one thing
people on the street right that's what
was happening and you were seeing these
like you go follow online like i just
yang my cab driver and my mom my grandma
it was like i like almost cry thinking
about it it was so [ __ ] heartwarming
and that's when i say
like the only reason this existed was
because of the yang gang because of the
supporters that's not a lie it's not a
[ __ ] like fluff puff piece that's
true like we we had to we had to do it
through
like a grassroots movement and it was
the definition of that you know
yeah so between february and june energy
is picking up uh we do a cnn town hall
you do all the pods too you do breakfast
club bench piro
pate america eventually
um
pre-parara you did a whole bunch of them
yeah yeah so that the so spring 2019 is
when
we're rising and becoming more serious
we basically went on like a national
tour
from joe rogan
in february through
the first debate
it was probably really april through may
we went on tour like a lot we did all
these all those big rally shots you see
the vast majority were before that june
debate
um
and we burnt everybody out
everybody because we were stupid about
it um
i uh optimistic about is probably the
better world like i think we were like
now it's time to go when we had been
grinding for a year and change you know
that was about the biggest one that was
uh because by the time we got to the
debate in miami
you were sick you're sick as a dog like
going into there um and we hadn't
figured out
frankly even lack of experience like how
to arrest you like we thought like oh
time in the family he'll be able to like
relax you got two little kids man it's
not a relaxing moment it's like more
stress um
so anyway that but that's we ended up
heading miami
you know what you love to do you know
what i love to do you know what you do
for six seven eight hours a day or night
it's sleep
and because we love to sleep so much we
really should be paying attention to the
mattress that we're sleeping on you can
get a mattress that's personalized for
you your body type your sleep
preferences at helix
sleep.com you can take a two-minute quiz
and they will send you a mattress risk
free don't take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine it's recommended by
chiropractors and doctors as a go-to
solution for improving your sleep just
go to helix sleep.com yang take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they will
match you to a customized mattress
10-year warranty 100 nights risk-free i
know it'd be weird to return a mattress
at 9.99 but you can do it helix even has
some financing options if you want to do
some kind of layaway action and helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
yang get the mattress to the sleepier
life helixsleep.com
[Music]
yeah so i i was sick i had this really
really nasty summer uh flu bug i do
think it was tied to the fact that like
you said would be just grindy grindy for
months yeah absolutely and so like i get
there i'm just like ugh
uh and that first debate goes badly um
we managed to survive because of and you
say in the book and i actually didn't
realize until i read your book
how much my not wearing a tie apparently
seemed to like help
deflect a narrative in a certain
direction there was that and then like
the microphone being off which helped so
the the struggle for me um was that
it's your first debate so you think oh
like what the hell's going on it turns
out this msnbc are just really like you
know jackasses
oh yeah and by the time the msnbc
moderated debate came up the next debate
which was like the fifth or sixth i was
like they're going to be jack we knew
what to expect yeah and then and then
they were jackasses and you were like
well that was like they they like didn't
ask me a question for 32 minutes like
this
yeah it was madness um
but the first time it was one of one so
you're like like what the hell was that
and the other thing is like well i mean
how are you supposed to you really how
how is one supposed to know how msnbc is
going to treat you because
there's not tape to review so the last
presidential you you're going back four
years right and so the last presidential
was three candidates right they're all
getting some relatively substantial air
time
there hasn't been a this crowded of a
presidential debate in the modern era
ever right so there was nothing to
compare it to it was just the
republican debate
which was fox and cnn and fox is
relatively fair like they
um i thought they did having watched a
bunch of those debates they did a good
job letting everybody get in um
and especially you know waited based on
polling
um so that first debate we are fortunate
to
survive you're sick trying to have a
coughing fit mike's off you're not
wearing it but not wearing a tie worked
really well
yeah so one thing i did not realize also
until reading your
was i supposed to wear a tie because i
thought i was i wasn't supposed to wear
a towel the whole time we had
loosely decided like you had said like
game time decision
you as a candidate you're like i'm all
right i get what you're saying we were
like we but like the team was like bei's
job interview in the world like we
should really consider a tie and that'll
show like good for our fans like
andrew's gonna take this seriously we
didn't think our fans would mind we
thought everybody else would mind
um
but we weren't like sold so but we had
like gone like you probably wear tie i
brought three i wouldn't brought them
unless we were going to do it and then i
remember very clearly like holding it up
and you're like [ __ ] out am i wearing
tie you could barely like you had a fog
around you this like fog
and i remember we did
barstool sports was doing they had like
a political podcast and we did that
before the debate um
with uh
pft one of their hosts and it would be
normally like a pretty big podcast like
excited about and you were like dead
you're like you're like we're cutting
this short and yeah i think you've ever
cut an interview short like that before
um
and so in the hindsight we should
reschedule that but uh
again like you learn a lot we both
learned like a lot of stuff on the fly
you know i'm going to say something too
that this is going to be like
somewhat distinct
maybe um so my brother had me read a
book uh called dances of intimacy like
years ago um and
he he said that in relationships you
have over functioners and under
functioners so this is in families in a
romantic relationship and so you think
of over functioning as good under
functioner is bad but the the problems
that over functioners end up
one they end up cultivating under
functioning in the people around them
because they're kind of overcompensating
so if you imagine like the super like
overachieving older brother um and then
maybe the younger brother ends up being
like uh slack or lay about okay rebel in
part because the older brother is like
kind of sucking that energy second
energy like filling that role yeah um so
uh it was you know it's a fun book but
yeah like but in in the business context
and certainly in the context of this
campaign
like i i was like this like stoic
over functioner where it's like well i'm
just gonna like battle battle battle and
we're we're gonna like you know do the
impossible together and the rest of it
um and so i i was just
you know like
grinding against the gears or like the
tire and so like if you have a more
balanced dynamic then at some point
you're like hey guys like you know like
maybe we should like uh
like take a little breather in in here
but that's not like the over-functioning
way you said a lot you said yes to
almost everything generally yeah and so
over-functioning at least from events so
so there's a common thread too like over
functioners in entrepreneurship because
they're like a lot of these like kind of
you know test your limits uh like push
push push
types and entrepreneurship
um and and for me romantically and in
terms of my personal relationships like
it took me until i was older because
what would happen was i'd be with
someone and then
um
like you know it's like i i was
not able to express
uh needs and vulnerabilities in like a
healthy productive way which by the way
i'm still not excellent at you know what
i mean like uh um
but
uh i think that the the fact that it
really took you
at some point just being like look guys
like yang needs a break like like in a
healthier thing maybe i would have been
like hey guys i could use a break but it
wasn't in me to be like hey guys i could
use a break because you're like
surrounded by a bunch of people and you
feel like okay
like i got to work harder than them
so they you know they're working this
hard i have to work harder yes like etc
etc i have a funny story on this it's
gonna fast forward but it's a funny
story um
so you
i've only seen you that sick twice uh so
that i write in the book like you were
notoriously like your reputation from
people i talked to
since i met you was that you just don't
get sick you don't take six days which
is generally true like you're pretty
much just a go go go um
so
but you got deathly sick twice on this
campaign one was right before the first
debate and the other one was right
before election day um great timing um
but you were
you were so you're dead i talked about
this a bit but you're dead on the bus
um we'll talk more about the bus but
you're dead you're lying on this bus
we're driving around iowa days and days
and you're like
you can't put your contacts in because
your eyes are all swollen
so you're doing the events you call them
daredevil style like blind you can't see
anybody
you would get you would do an event
you'd get on the bus take your shoes off
take your jacket off put it over your
head and pass out for two hours and then
to be nudged by someone begrudgingly
wake up and do the same thing you do
like four or five times a day it's the
worst way to recover from whatever
sickness you had
there was a guy
who you know it is i'm gonna name
nameless just but i have to say because
the story's so funny um he's like a
friend of your like a relative friend of
yours and he's like
he comes in and he's like we're [ __ ]
here we're here for the yeah we're here
to yang we're joining the bus you're
like what what are you doing here he's
like yeah yang said it's cool and he was
like a friend of yours like yeah yeah
zach it's fine so this guy's sitting
there
you are literally like jacking over
[ __ ] head
dying of god knows what and he's trying
to have a conversa he's on the bus as
you said he's a friend of yours he's
trying to have a conversation with you
and i'm like
i think i'm gonna lose my [ __ ] mind
i'm looking at team like i'm gonna i'm
going to lose it like i'm going like i
know you see me blow my gasket once in a
while and i don't like yell all the time
but when i do it's like a [ __ ] ordeal
i'm like i'm gonna [ __ ] lose it and
i'm like oh [ __ ] stay away from that so
next stop
i like pulled him over his side and i
was like
you're getting off this [ __ ] bus what
the [ __ ] are you doing and he's like
what do you how do you see this playing
my mind the man is literally he's
running for president he's literally
dead right now
and the guy looked at me he's like well
i know i thought we'd come hang out hang
on iowa and like you know good to see
him maybe get dinner after and i'm like
what do you think this is a [ __ ] rock
concert it's like a band tour you know
hang out with the band he's sick he's
got a 90 100 degree fever on there he's
lying and i'm screaming at him now and
what do you think we're going to go hang
out at [ __ ] chili's we're not doing
that get the [ __ ] off the bus i don't
want to see you again
get so i'm screaming in a parking lot
and sanchez to this day our press
secretary eric sanchez anytime like
something happens he's like what are we
going to [ __ ] chili's like since then
but yeah we just left him in like
dubuque like the middle of no i'm like
you'll be fine i don't care um
so long way saying uh it would
yeah it was tough for by the end we got
better at managing it um
but
you are not particularly one to uh
like you're gonna push the limit if you
get the option right uh and it was
towards the end i just think yeah you
know like i can soldier through what's
the worst thing to happen yeah the
reason happens you die it works that
happens this gets you you just die well
the other thing is like you
the other thing it's like and this is
one thing i learned in politics like
there's certain
types of and everybody's different but
there's certain activities that
you know an hour or two hours doing one
thing is not the same as an hour and two
hours doing another thing and i don't
mean like physical activity but like in
terms of mental energy well this is the
thing that nobody knows except for
candidates
and so you think to yourself it's like
okay like i can work long hours
um but if someone sticks a mic in front
of your face and then it's like hey
you're gonna say something and by the
way if you like say the wrong thing then
you know we're we're going to like splay
it on networks around the
country so you have like a certain form
of mental exertion i know that feeling
and then when you go in front of like a
group of people
and then you give remarks and shake
hands and like they say to you like hey
i really care about this and you say
like oh like you know tell me more tell
me more and i really want to do
something about that that's like a
different form of exertion and a lot of
these things are kind of social or
psychic or emotional exertions
that uh tax you in a particular way
um and
unless you're frankly like just either
like super duper extroverted or just a
crazy person
like a normal human can't do that stuff
for more than x hours a day without
uh like you know
like
messing up burning out um like something
your brain brain starts to turn to mush
yeah your brain starts to turn to
martial are you just you know that you
start like
saying gibberish or like you know or
probably say the wrong thing like a lot
of the things that you see
uh from political figures it's like you
know like a lot of them just get worn
out uh at
a point in time and so like it's a
different form of work
it's something that i had not
anticipated even when i was deciding to
run for office because they're like oh
this will be sort of like being an
entrepreneur i'll be sort of like
starting a nonprofit um it's different
because like the point no it's not yeah
it stops being about that because it
ends up being much much more personal
and one of the things that we're scared
shitless of right now is that we sense
that our political figures are
essentially becoming um actors and
theater performers and they are they
have to be the system cuts them that way
and that's you were
this is a good point like up to this was
the transition for us like up to
essentially the miami debate but
definitely up to joe rogan so the first
debate you were like a ceo like you were
yes you were the front man like doing
that but generally
like i i had you know controlling other
folks on the team or con you know ran
the operation you delegate well but the
other day we were running through you
and we had to shift to
you like the candidate because the job
is so hard and the other thing is you
talk about yes you're you're exhausted
and you've got people that came to see
you for miles wherever they are so you
want to bring it for them you want to
give be the real you want to care about
what they're saying you want to take a
good selfie you want to give the good
speech the good interview but uh you
want to do the fundraiser well and raise
the money but then there's other things
too and we do all that and then be like
okay man this next hour
you need to prep for
this debate you need to prep for cnn
town hall you need to read about the
middle east you need to read about xyz
and like
certain people and you at times was like
that's the last thing in the world you
wanna [ __ ] do right then you're like
i wanna i need to sleep or i need to
turn my brain off can we play video
games like you know anything right
and that's hard and
for us as an inexperienced team
um
this is a this is a problem i've worked
now you know talk to experience
consultants they have the same problem
but definitely us from inexperienced
team
especially the younger staffers or folks
are not interacting with you on a
day-to-day basis we're like why isn't
andrew doing this why isn't andrew doing
more like you're [ __ ] kidding me like
there's literally physically you know
like they don't understand the human
toll of this right um
and certain people
are wired a certain way you know like
uh you're an introvert right so you're
not you're exerting energy when you're
talking to people some people get energy
right um and if you're an extrovert you
probably have energy coming off a bus
and then you could do more work it's a
different different but every can is
different
yeah i mean i'd liken it to let's say
you had someone who's like a broadway
performer and then they would
have a show every night and then they'd
like you know rest and do the rest of it
like would you have that broadway
performer
do
uh
three shows a day four shows a day um
and then would you have them do four
shows a day every day
and then do that seven days a week and
then do that for like like it doesn't
make any sense because you'd be like no
i would have you do it like you know
once a day
and then i'd have you go do something
else and blah blah so so when you're the
candidate it is like
you're
doing like any number of shows a day and
people don't realize too you know it's
like you think i mean all of my stuff
was genuine i mean it was me
um but there is still like uh
like
that kind of like okay it's time to turn
it on yes of course
and i've been around now you know like
actors movie stars comedians politicians
uh like countless tv hosts and there is
an on switch on just about everyone like
like
no one acts like that stuff
until the cameras the number one thing i
get from a lot of people when they meet
you
uh for the first time like actually
you're like wow he's just kind of the
same guy you see on tv and the answer
yeah yes you are you are on you're more
aware but you're essentially the same
human
that is not the case for the vast
majority of tv hosts we work with don
lemon was kind of the same on and off
camera i found and i think some of the
cnn folks were you know better than me
obviously
um
but
they were folks they just don't say
[ __ ] anything and then bang we're on
and they're like a whole new human um
and i get it like it's
exer i mean i just imagine like
the folks that like if you did the today
show or something like every morning at
four in the morning like you're just a
shell of a human being until the camera
comes on you know uh the first time i
was on live tv i was very very
uh bewildered because the people would
just be like ignoring you looking at
notes and then all of a sudden someone
said notice and then so you're sitting
there and you're like first time you're
like what's going on yeah and then the
camera's on and everyone's like
zach we love you now yeah yeah it's
awful it's absolutely awful um so
so the first debate doesn't go well and
then you make a command decision to be
like look like yang needs a bit of break
and then a debate training camp which
was fascinating in that
we
didn't have i suppose like professional
uh coaches come in um until then
and so leading up to the second debate
we have
um
a communications guy and like a
substance and policy guy yeah um and
uh it was like a like a revelation of me
i was like oh my gosh we need to learn
how to debate like a tv debate tv debate
which we were really we were a little
arrogant
in
you you got the message out every other
way and every other format every single
live event podcast i was like this is
[ __ ] different man it's like it's
it's a reality tv show as you said but
it's also this like ping pong [ __ ]
and if you get in you got to be ready to
take heat um
it's like instead of a debate i started
to see it as a competitive distributed
media
performance
and i mean look the whole thing's
[ __ ] and it does not correlate to
being a good president realistically um
except that you can handle a crucible i
guess which is maybe that's a strong
correlation i'm not sure um
but
yeah we put you through well so and this
was not a great very popular decision on
the team like we didn't have a great
debate and we had one more to go and i'm
like and we're going on vacation uh but
uh
you gotta make those calls and this was
needed so we have you got you got rest
uh i got a little rest but mainly you
gotta build up a team and then we put
you through basically three weeks of
debate hell um it wasn't hell hell it
was like nine to five you know we wanted
to stay again i actually felt really
good during that because my schedule was
more normal and i was like oh yeah yeah
and it was here it was summer
uh i was away from my family which had
its uh pluses and minuses pros and cons
yep
[Music]
so going into the second debate
i'm feeling
really good because one i'm healthy and
i was like oh there's better when you're
healthy um but two is in detroit which i
thought was a really good bacteria by a
lot of friends in detroit i'd spent a
lot of time there
i felt like i
understood uh the midwest and the issues
and it was very on theme for the
campaign
but the biggest difference was that cnn
moderated and cnn was fair they like
asked me automation questions
they they
gave you some air time yeah they took it
seriously um and
i felt like wow this is a million times
better um
on multiple levels so that we had a glow
up we got you a haircut
new suit if i recall you look sharp yeah
zac started attending to a bunch of
uh theatrical details which by the way
was good for my marriage so thank you so
that was yeah yeah what was that it was
like all right if we're gonna
we learned everything the hard way
frankly the first debate and in round
two we're like so i said you can't bring
fans and then we got to the the thing in
miami so we follow the rules like all
right we're not going to bring fans we
got to miami and
it's like a [ __ ] home game for kamala
harris and warren i'm like well this is
[ __ ] so then we went to detroit and
we brought the scream team shout out
lacy and pam who uh and a few others
that uh and they just went nuts anytime
you spoke which probably felt pretty
good
um
and we were prepared we knew what to
[ __ ] do we knew how to like
basically you don't actually answer the
question you uh have a bunch of points
that you're trying to hit uh and deflect
it and inhale your hammer your message
over and over yeah so that was good fun
uh we had a closing that talked about
how last time everyone was just fixated
on my not wearing a tie and we did
that's
yeah um
but uh
drawing back attention to the no tie
which is good it was full circle yeah so
that was july um and then shortly
thereafter we qualified for the
september october debates so we blew up
a bit in july things are going well um
we essentially get
not a summer off but it's a little more
relaxed in august well just they don't
have august so we just did our thing um
a couple more rallies
uh
preparing for the debate doing we're
able to hire a south carolina team and
nevada teams it is funny how like when i
think about this time
my head naturally does go to the debates
because they they were monthly
they were something of a benchmark every
time if you didn't make it you die
even though we grew to realize that it's
like look these debates aren't often
very game-changy
um where even like the kamala sticks
into joe biden like that bomb faded uh
by the next debate i think
um so so the the debates were
um like not a like
you know not as significant as i think
we we all like to hype them up to be but
i still think about them
the first one or two
i think and then you can do the counter
example where obviously like bloomberg's
debate performance was
crushed it was bad enough where the you
know campaign can't recover so there are
there are instances where it's like okay
you know like these debates can be
important if you have like an outlier
negatively
i would argue it's very difficult to
have an outlier positively because
um so you can have an outlier negatively
especially the presidential like the
the general election debates it's like
everybody's kind of entrenched um
especially pat so like i would say
generally
they
i think it's a zero-sum game here
they're either massively useful because
you're you're learning who the
candidates are and that's like kind of
the best way they can do it i think you
should do podcast long form but you
would lose a lot of your viewers
but they're also a massive waste of time
and money so
i think you know i would do
fewer debates in a variety of formats if
i was in charge i would do one of these
[ __ ] crazy prime time ones
and then i would do
like a long form one podcast style or
you know like no audience super long
like very chill
like a joe rogan type moderated debate i
will say too that in terms of the energy
around me and my recognizability on the
street uh the debates were a massive
where
like the average casual american
correct saw something over the debates
it was like oh wait like you know yang
yeah you know so between joe rogan and
the presidential debates this is when
i
became recognized on the street we
started getting taken off a bit it's
like 20 million people 18 million people
watched the first two debates
essentially 18 to 12. um
and then there's millions upon millions
of people that get the recaps
and you talk in the book about our
strategy in the houston debate yeah
where
i vividly remember someone sitting me
down
and saying hey
this debate's gonna be really boring
because uh abc is really boring uh and
the the you're probably gonna have one
opportunity to make any kind of mark
it's probably gonna be your first answer
so what do you think about us giving
money away yes uh and i
well i think we actually ran through a
number of different possibilities and
then settled on giving money away and
then i became
favorable i was like well you know it's
like it's on theme like might as well
just make this about what the campaign
is so this was like the attention
economy thing we're looking at so we did
some mock debates and they were fun
apparently this is novel and it's
shocking to me that we hired actors to
play
various candidates and bought like
rented an auditorium and simulated the
actual debate
and then we did so we did that for
detroit to really get him ready for that
and then we did it again for houston
and
that was when that was the first like
level up debate was only 10 candidates
left and they were all like what's
called the pro debaters and all had
their own brands and political skill
and followings
we're like we're just gonna get lost up
there the same way everybody was like it
was just like no one's gonna get any
love off this debate really
um
so like but we needed love because we
were only at two percent you know we
needed to get more and so
like what we got to do a stunt
essentially what the [ __ ] do we do like
we already did the no tie thing we did
the thousand a month thing like there
was how do you differentiate
and we could you know you go to your
head like you could attack a candidate
it's not always great like you look at
the numbers and that stuff it's not
particularly awesome like tulsi gabbard
for example like
chewed out tim ryan i think the first
debate like neither of them did great
after that like you could go down
uh and some of these bigger candidates
they'll punch back a lot like going
after liz warren you look at bloomberg i
was not great um
so
being the free money guy it was and so
we hyped it up um
we gave away a thousand dollars to
uh a month to ten different to
ten different families and i
you know obviously we knew i wrote all
about this like we knew it was a gimmick
right and we knew pizza would people
would hate it the pundits would hate it
um but it was on brand
um
and we figured people would forget about
it that it was a gimmick and you'd get
your pulling bump and you'd be able to
keep existing for a while and if people
knew you as the guy who gave away money
it's not bad i'm not about to hate it i
didn't hate the asian oprah thing what
was [ __ ] crazy dude was
[Music]
so the pundits like shat on us when this
first happened right um but we had i
wrote like it was like two million
people went to our website in like a
matter of seconds it was like the
website almost like we prepared prepared
for
millions upon millions people to go to
the website and it broke for a little
bit there's that many like and this is
amazon servers like they don't have that
many people go to one website at one
time like instantly like that um
so
uh
we were you were the third most searched
i think the third most searched topic in
the [ __ ] world that night um like we
we thought we had blown up before no we
blew we blew up and that was when you
couldn't go anywhere without being
recognized after that one debate um
and what was fun was all the pundits who
had talked [ __ ] about this debate
strategy like changed their tune very
quickly in like 48 hours when we
announced how many people came on the
website how many donors we got how many
emails we got we raised a ton of money
uh and we bumped in polling we qualified
for the next two it was like pretty much
overnight like bang and then it was just
like as if it never happened
um which makes me think in hindsight we
should have done more stunts
um
but
uh
yeah you know i don't know if actually
would have worked but this one works so
well um maybe we should have tried to
keep pushing the envelope but the
problem is and we've talked about this
in this podcast before is that
if we were republicans it would have
worked
more stunts would work because they hate
the press only 75 of the republicans
don't really trust the media and
mainstream press is that high geez i
thought it was only a three-quarter jeez
uh and the dems are what 65 trust it 69
69 yeah so this is why you're the
numbers guy uh i've i get close enough
for government work uh
but
like dems trust the press so if they
were [ __ ] on you all the time it
wasn't we didn't think that was a
winning strategy um and sadly it's
probably right so
but that was our level up now at that
point dude
i thought i thought after either july
or september we had a real shot to go on
win which i know sounds that sounds wild
but i was on the impression i don't know
about you i wasn't impressed the hard
part was done
like we got you were a thing you know
like the hardest part was going from
zero to a contender like top ten top
five
uh the rest part like winning obviously
hard but if you did all that stuff
before that you're there for a reason
you're there because you have the
potential to win i thought that was a
very logical conclusion to say who the
[ __ ] is this guy like right and that was
couldn't have been more wrong um
could not have been more wrong uh that
was like that's as far as we got
actually the polling pretty much after
that debate was as high as we went
even despite lots of ad spending
well we got uh so the the next debate
threshold was three percent we qualify
and then four percent uh we qualify and
uh we keep on rumbling along we run we
got good polls then so we had you know
uh for a while but we didn't draw per se
to your point the problem really came
in trying to transition to
a broader appeal and base uh and i
remember you coming to me during the
campaign and you put in the book where
you're like okay
there's the the yang
brand and it's
no
fun
positive
iconoclastic uh
these are democrats we're talking about
and we need to try and broaden you to
become more acceptable to like the
average mainstream democratic primary
voter right so what we want you to do is
to strike a different tone
be uh
be
more serious and we're going to use this
particular speech as the launching point
and i heard this and i said make sense
and then i
learned a great new speech learned a
great new speech kids are not all right
great speech and then we debuted it
in iowa we got a thousand people show up
with that rivers cuomo played in weezer
we like rolled out for this thing yeah
yeah we put a lot of energy into it and
i would say that
that speech uh evelyn was there um
was
one of the high points of the campaign
still in my mind
because i thought i did a really good
job i saw the other candidates and i saw
frankly myself and i was like i
felt like
uh i was one of like the the top
um
performances of the night christmas i
was getting texts from reporters and
friends and friends on the campaigns
speech at night i put this in book
speech of the night wow your boy came to
play tonight i'm in tears it was a very
good speech it was a presidential speech
in many ways
and then uh afterwards it was like it
never happened like the press you
weren't in the room it did not exist
yeah and that was like a very very
strange feeling um and so this is when
and we talked about this in the book
where uh
like that there was like a degree of
mainstream
credibility or acceptability that uh the
press did not want to give us correct uh
and that was one of the clearest
examples i remember because i was like
look i felt like i did my job you know
like my job was to deliver
uh a strong message
uh in a way that would stick
uh
and that was one of the things too that
like from being around these other
candidates and campaigns it's like you
know they're human beings i'm a human
being we all do our thing
um but then everything gets refracted
through like this media mirror because
obviously 99.9 percent of people are not
in the room they're not like watching us
deliver these things so they'll just
take cues from whatever of course uh
from whatever the press says this is the
game man and this was also during the
time period during which like we started
having the the yang media blackout um
particularly with msnbc
uh we left off polls and not many
graphics the whole thing it was just
ridiculous like the most ridiculous was
when i qualified for the california
debate i was the last
i was the only
non-white candidate on that stage and it
was like a piece of political news that
everyone just reports it's like andrew
yang qualifies for
uh you know debate number six uh and
msnbc wouldn't even report that yeah
because i was like i was curious at the
time i was like well they have to report
that i mean you can't just like like
pretend that that didn't happen
and they did they were like ed like you
know and i was like okay like this is
really ridiculous
it was uh it was a really tough swallow
because like i said like i thought this
would be the point where we start to
take off like from the mainstream and so
there's a couple reasons for it right um
one as i say like they do have a level
of
trust with voters that the republicans
don't have the democrat like the
mainstream media and the democrats have
a deeper relationship um and you need to
get that blessing in the democratic
party at least as of today like you need
that
um
we did everything we could to not get
that in the early days
because we did everything we could
because we were being ignored so we were
doing like hey look at me all the time
and so
once we had finally let's call earned
the ability to get the mainstream
coverage they didn't want to give it
right um
because we had done all this let's call
it gimmicks or things that they they
didn't approve of i have a slightly
different what do you think about it
um by the way i think there's more to it
than i just said but yeah no i like i
just i don't think we were going to get
it no matter what probably right like it
wasn't like oh you did these other like
you know
like not non-serious things so now i
can't like give you serious coverage
it's like they didn't want to cover us
from the beginning and then they didn't
want to give us serious coverage yes
you got that in your mayor's race too
man where it's like you know
they
this the left media in particular
they're king makers they find you when
you run for city council and then state
rep and then
local congressional rep and like like up
the chain and so there's like that's
what they want and you think about the
candidates they've approved like bernie
got a lot of hate too and he's like
well like not that he was immune to the
sitting centers like not really off the
beaten path but uh
more so than the rest right and so
um i think to me the biggest example was
amy klobuchar which like she had an okay
debate
she's good right but nothing like no
world-beating performance in these
debates where she got a ton of coverage
down the stretch and bumped like 15
points
the message didn't change the moment
didn't change it wasn't like a core
piece of her policy which i'm not sure i
like the midwest is the policy there um
that nothing and that changed it was
just the press covered her more right
that earned media piece and so you
needed that blessing and so the analogy
i use in the book is um
what i call bud light marketing is you
need to be
so why does bud light advertise they
don't advertise because
they have a new product or it's bud
light it's been the same forever it
doesn't taste like anything it tastes
like water uh they advertise to
normalize it so if someone orders a bud
light
no one gives you a funny look um and
doritos you go down the list and why
these these brands advertise um
but you were i say you know if uh we
need to be bud light but you were
uh
420 sweetwater pale you were
yeah was that sweet water yeah um
you were you're a sweet water like craft
beer uh
delicious and like better than bud light
in every point right where i was like if
you want it because it's more locally
sourced or it'll get you drunker or it
tastes better it's got a cooler bottle
like
going on a list but if you did a taste
test today or ask people would they
rather have bud light or sweet water
across the country they would all pick
like the majority of pick bud light
because they're familiar with it uh it's
less risky and that's kind of where
we're at and the things we had to do
to get attention to get in the game were
sweet water
beer
activities but we needed to get the bud
light activities and uh
that wasn't us
and you know as i said this book but guy
here won't get you there and that's
partially true there's all the parts
like they weren't ever going to line up
behind you i don't think we could have
run up you could have done it better and
i don't think you came out victorious
there either you know
[Music]
so down the stretch of the campaign um
thank you yang gang we're raising money
which means that consultants show up
and then the consultants are like hey
you need some tv ads and then we film
said tv ads and that was such a trip for
me when we were at that point um and i
remember you all seeing the ads and
being like oh like this one and don't
like that one as much
but but filming them was such a trip and
we spent
seven million dollars on ads in iowa
where i would get into the hotel at
night in
iowa
and then i would turn on the tv
and then there'd be my ad
and then there'd be the elizabeth warren
ad and then there'd be the the joe biden
if you watch tv in iowa it's just ad
it's awful god bless the people of iowa
we were inundating people and i remember
uh sitting with the consultants and they
were like look we've moved iowans on
all of these things about you like cares
about people like me has
uh new ideas understands uh the economy
wants to have a beer with like i i was
shooting up in all of these
measurements um
the only measurement i couldn't shoot up
on was like i'm going to vote for this
guy to be president united states had
the experience
i mean it's because like has the
experience uh
necessary to be president um i scored
low on and so there were a lot of people
that were like well like yang
um not gonna vote for him oh the two
things i failed on number one
experience and number two can defeat
donald trump oh yeah at the end of the
day the single biggest factor for
democratic primary voters was which of
these candidates will beat donald trump
and eventually they landed on joe biden
which by the way happened to be accurate
it worked like joe well half the country
doesn't believe that but yes it worked
he did but
uh and that in a way is understandable
because
if you liked yang but you're like well
this guy's still somewhat new and
untested and proven are we really going
to bet like the fate of the country on
that yeah and him to defeat trump it's
like i'll just go with joe um and that
was
the so that that became our reality when
uh caucus night hit in iowa yeah and
there were hundreds of people from
around the country thank you again yang
yang who showed up volunteered one guy
dislocated his kneecap and just and like
you know and in the ice and snowball
that's very cool wow yeah and then still
just kept on going and like freaking
like a wheelchair um and we got 8914 uh
votes which was 24 of the approximately
40 000 that we that we need
uh
unfortunately because of the 15
rule like are zero you out pretty
quickly they zero you up pretty quick if
you're not above
um a certain threshold so that the
ultimate winners
um
uh
bernie got i think like 42 000 votes or
something like that um which was what
i'd projected that we would need
initially um so our
uh five percent like displays as one
percent because of the the fifteen
percent right
um rule and so we end up with a really
tough night i gotta say
um there were different emotions i had
during the talent of the campaign and we
were fighting very hard we're
campaigning very hard a lot of energy a
lot of volunteers everything else um the
numbers we're showing it's like look
you're having trouble moving your top
line
um but it was really only when i walked
into that polling site
the caucus site
in
uh des moines where i was like oh [ __ ]
like this
yeah this is not gonna be our night you
lino we're like yeah this isn't gonna go
well for us tonight yeah
yeah cause you go in
and there's like a small pocket of yang
signs that comprise you know four or
five percent of the
gym which is about what we got uh and
then there are signs for everyone else
everywhere
um and uh we wound up with five percent
which got zero down in that station um
but but imagine being the candidate so
what happened was i was the only
candidate in that gym that night yeah i
mean every candidate goes to one spot
yeah it goes through different things so
you know this was our weird if we were
all in the same place but you had
different people giving statements on
behalf of different campaigns and then
it's like andrew yang's here yeah and
i'm like yeah then you know people give
me like polite applause even though most
of them are not fans of mine yeah i give
a nice speech and then i get warmer
applause after the speech and then a
couple people but like hey you know what
like that was good yeah and i'm gonna
caution you i'm like oh thank you yeah
um but i remember one woman came to me
and said please run again yeah and and i
heard that and was like well in a way
that's like a high compliment you know
but in a way that's like definitely not
going to happen
uh yeah it was uh
so yeah the money in iowa so yeah i
think we had i have a couple things to
say so one was the strategy where i was
like go in
you go all in in iowa or you could skip
iowa go to new hampshire you could skip
both of them and go to south carolina or
nevada first
when we lost iowa
we didn't have a great night we could
zero it out in iowa then and the problem
with iowa is that you needed 15 in a
whole bunch of districts to even play
ball that's there's a threshold there so
you can you know at 10 in iowa
theoretically wonderful but it would we
would have the same exact we doubled our
score would have essentially the same
result there
um which is why i was bad like a tough
first date but the problem was
if the whole thing was about press
attention which it was and we were not
getting any
saying that we don't like the
traditional process like [ __ ] you iowa
we're going to new hampshire or south
carolina was not a good way to get
legitimacy in mainstream coverage it was
actually a worse way and you could argue
that's what happened
i think with
tulsi and um
what's his name the billionaire tom
steyer um
where they said we're going to go south
carolina directly or go new hampshire
directly and they got no coverage
leading up to the race and then
underperformed in both of their states
um because of the lack of coverage so
iowa got us a good amount of mainstream
coverage if you're on the cover of the
des moines register as part of it like
you were in the hunt you know um
but it did suck a moment i looked at it
and i
think we made the right decision because
i agree with you if you skipped iowa
then it was like okay like what was
really going to happen were you really
going to break out new hampshire
crushing new hampshire after everybody
talks about the winner of iowa yeah in
in that way
um i i do regret that and we should talk
about the the decision to suspend um i
do regret that i didn't get to
uh
um
count the votes in nevada you want to go
to nevada and south carolina yeah i was
just in nevada last week and had a blast
thank you nevada but um
but i remember
we have a tough night in iowa
and then i give a
speech to iowan supporters
and then i put a positive face on it
because they still hadn't officially
counted the votes um and then we're off
my head but we kind of knew that debacle
they know that we'd uh gotten below the
threshold and then we landed in new
hampshire for a week of campaigning like
it was again like event after event um
we're off the bus because the buses are
too big for the roads of new hampshire
so we're in in
rental vehicles and suvs
uh
and uh somewhere in the middle of that
week uh you and the team sit me down and
say hey
your call but uh we think you should
consider suspending the campaign if new
hampshire doesn't go well not a fun
combo oh so what was your lead in to sit
down have this because i remember being
on the receiving end of that convo
it was uh so you're talking with the
team you're like okay new hampshire
like you know you basically know a
couple days after caucus like all right
are we the story out of iowa no
like we're getting less coverage than we
had before
we put way more money on tv in iowa than
we did in new hampshire like it's not
going to go out it's not going to go
well for us now new hampshire is always
a stronger state for us so and there's
it's uh
you don't have to like you had open
registration i think um
so there was a chance we over-performed
but we weren't confident and then it was
like okay
we had a movement that we built
and it was what do we do because i was
like i was worried i was like i knew you
you were like i'm going to convention
makes all the sense in the world
and i think that does if you're trying
to get the message out and you were like
a no-name candidate going out but you
would now become a real candidate
and uh we were like i think
you know talking internally like i think
if we drag this out it becomes as
like you go back you almost go first
full circle back to the illegitimate
candidate we were early
and the fear was
doing damage to the movement instead of
how serious it had become and so you go
out and the best thing when you drop out
everybody no one wants the dems to go
back to playing nice again so
uh the best press coverage you ever got
was the night you dropped out everybody
in the world all these famous people
calling you and telling you how great
you are because you're no longer a
threat to the status quo um but yeah
like going in is like i think i remember
letting you straight like hey
i'll stick with you because i'm your
friend but
uh
we're gonna have to fire a lot of people
like we're not gonna raise any money if
we do this uh if you stay on
um but you remember i remember you
saying this very clearly like okay we'll
have a contingency plan but we're
fighting like [ __ ] hell this week
because i'm not
we're not doing if we want to drop out
you know to be lame we'll do it now
we're not doing that we're going to
fight to win new hampshire and if we
don't win then we make the call we're
ready to rock
um
so yeah that was a wild wild week behind
the scenes if you will
yeah and
uh
i
remember really enjoying that week in
new hampshire but there was like also a
lot of energy a lot of volunteers had
some really good events yep um but you
always you get the crowds that was an
issue people wanted to hang out with you
wanted to be with you on a photo with
you like the youth vote
was just actually voting for you
yeah but
the returns came back that night too as
well and it was clear relatively early
that it wasn't happening so we got
chicken fingers at puritans
still good
yes miss you new hampshire love you too
yeah uh and
uh i remember deciding to suspend and
it was really tough like the the
toughest thing actually was going to
nevada the next day and uh people were
in tears i got a lot of messages that's
right we had a big thing playing in
nevada the next day saying like oh you
know what happened there were a lot of
people that were just stunned that it
was over
uh
and
you know looking back on it again
um i don't think we made the wrong
decision
um
but
yeah it was it was a very very rough
period and it felt like you'd just been
running
100 miles an hour and then all of a
sudden like like you're like a cartoon
character where you're like running in
the clip
the ground runs out yep
uh so
what uh 48 hours that was that there
were there were a lot of people calling
me at that point like obviously all the
candidates that were still in it were
calling me to
congratulate me and nudge me in the way
of endorsing them
so that was yeah that was interesting
[Music]
let me ask you this so one of the things
there's a chapter
there's a chapter i took out of the book
because it was too negative really uh
are just like hey
there's too much haterade in this
chapter but i'm curious your thoughts
and maybe
outtakes maybe long shot out takes long
shot out takes so i wrote a whole
chapter on
the war on normal people is
driven by political consultants
and oh dude this chapter are totally
gold and i took it out maybe i'll share
it at some point i took it out because
it had nothing to do with the [ __ ]
story but it was so i wanna and maybe
talk about this in the pod before but
like okay you're running let's paint
this picture if you're running for
office
there is no
real
institutional knowledge for campaigns
you know what i'm saying like if you
start in like the world of finance like
there's people that have worked at
multiple firms and there's like best
practices shared across banks and
institutions orgs and that's true for
almost every industry insurance and
education you go to that list right
but what is it for politics because
these campaigns they die they're like
six months to two years max right and so
there's no longevity there um and if you
go work on the hill that's a separate
federally regulated entity then your
campaign right those are somewhat
federally regulated or whatever they are
state regulated but it's different
um
so what's the institutional knowledge
for
the politics we all know which is mainly
campaigning
and it ends up becoming consultants and
so what happens is you're andrew yang
and you're running for office or you're
zach gromin you run a run for office and
what do you need you need somebody who
has press relationships to talk to
people and who has press relationships
is someone who can stay on a multiple
campaigns that ends up becoming a
consultant
you want to get some polling done who
runs polls over and over can compare
them over time it ends up being a
consultant that works with lots of
campaigns you go down the list like
someone who like knows how to fundraise
across multiple races you need a
fundraising consultant you need someone
who does research on all of the people
in your district uh and you're in the
state of new york i've researched all
the candidates hire a research
consultant
the institutional knowledge in politics
is consultants and you have to the
problem is you have to have them because
they have relationships you will not
have um
you can't that no amount of money can
help you avoid this [ __ ] because you
need to hire
someone needs to do political polls
someone needs to be able to like try
that or trustworthy someone needs to do
[ __ ] comm stuff so
the problem is
it's not like a consultant like bain or
mckenzie that you and i would hire when
you're an entrepreneur or they have like
aligned incentives with you generally
speaking uh where you hire them to do a
task i want you to figure out this xyz
problem and they come back to you with a
report and whether or not you can do it
or not or they bless xyz these
consultants
theoretically are supposed to help you
win but that's not their incentive their
incentive is to
make money and get more clients down the
road so their incentive is to help you
win to a point where they don't get
embarrassed and they can lose and still
look good and that is the delta range
that's awful and for someone like you
that's trying to win
uh
you know they'll never like a reporter
write something bad about you
and you want to go hammer them they're
going to press you the other direction
because they have a relationship with
that reporter and they made in writer
may need them to write a piece in their
next race they may be working on four or
five other races where that reporter is
also writing things
uh
they need they need that they think the
if they if a pollster they hired came
out with a did a [ __ ] job they may be
working with them on other races may
need to work with them in the future
digital marketing you go down the list
there's a political industrial complex
that kind of sits on top of everything
and it's
if you look this is where i wrote the
chapter like look at joe biden's
administration who are they they're all
political consultants it's everywhere
they run the [ __ ] world dude and like
some are great some are awful more awful
than great beyonce um but they run
everything because that's who ends up
working that's who works on the hill
that's who works in the staffers there
just becomes a way to make and that's
the real way to make money
in politics so yeah i don't know your
thoughts on this but this
irked me big time well i i think that
hits home for a lot of people uh and
it's one reason why people are so fed up
and frustrated it's like the these
forces kind of keep the status quo in
place yes um that there's a lot of money
built in and if you go against the
machine
then the machine tries to stick it to
you
in various ways and the machine is
powerful because they can easily build
up another candidate very quickly
very quickly and it takes a trump like
the reality is like trump was able to
both like bulldoze his way through all
this because he was not only was he
super rich do you forget but he was 99.9
name recognition super famous super
famous and like that's rare those combos
are almost like elon musk the only one i
think right and he overrode
a party that was very very uh
institutionally weak yes that was filled
with voters who did not care didn't give
a [ __ ] about the establishment so this
is my fundamental insight in why i
started the forward party yeah was that
people on the left you want to do the
same thing the democratic party i'm like
no no it's going to be much much harder
the democratic party because 69 trust
the media because half of them want the
party become more conservative not less
a bit because they're going to kneecap
you at every turn and the example i use
is look democrats at 75 percent of the
legislature in california a governor who
ran on single parent health care
couldn't even bring it to a vote
you know like the machine i love that
story by the way for your example yeah
at this point the the democratic party
and the machine are
um like you know
85 percent overlapping
um and and so you're like oh i'm gonna
like turn the machine to all these other
ends it's like no no no yeah like if you
get bernie
and put all the establishment voters
aren't going to follow that's your point
they want to be
more conservative like it's not the far
left doesn't have the support that the
far right does in terms of its like
ability to bulldoze well well they're
trying to bulldoze a a much stronger um
yeah that's a better way to yes you know
it's like you you have like all these uh
roadblocks uh you know in terms of the
money i mean you're looking at like
billions of dollars that's poured into
the coffers of the democratic party
which also is going to be a force for
status quo yeah any meaningful change
you want to make is going to end up
running afoul of like a whole panoply of
corporate interests yes and this is like
if you look at cory booker
and i lo we like cory booker i like him
a lot but you look at cory booker when
he was like mayor of newark to who he is
today in terms of substance of what he
says it's night and day and it's nothing
against cory booker frankly seriously
because
it's human nature to do this but you
start off and you that you're idealistic
and you're real and you're [ __ ]
bucking the trends and you're doing your
thing but you have to raise money
and crowdfunding is frankly a recent
thing which wasn't a huge thing was
corey when corey was taking off
so you end up going to what they call
bundlers who are people that know a
whole bunch of other rich people who
love politics and they can say hey i'll
raise you a hundred thousand dollars
plus and they get
lots and lots of rich people will come
to your events now what happens you meet
all these people they have your phone
number they're max donors they blah blah
blah and you end up listening to them
and it's just
years and years and years of these
people dripping in your head and it's a
small subset of people and they're all
highly political so what do they read
what does that mean they're reading the
new york times and they're listening to
msnbc and they're following politico and
they're not in touch with reality the
way the average americans are and you
end up skewing towards either nothing or
like a just a puppet yeah i think uh max
donors represent i want to say it was
literally like a fraction of a percent
of uh of the american people it's 69 000
people yeah so it's uh
you know it's not a normal perspective i
was actually thinking of the corporate
layer of money like the billions of
dollars that are right on top of it when
you talk about the two major parties
yeah like that there's a ton of money uh
you know
like everything you look at the national
convention it's like wall-to-wall
corporate sponsors and everything else
so aoc said she walked in and goldman
sachs was the sponsor for her like
uh orientation orientation [ __ ]
kidding me
yeah so
come on come on
so
uh
what's wild is that we had a an
amazingly successful campaign and yet to
your point like we still didn't truly
come
close to winning yeah in the way that uh
there were moments when it's like oh my
gosh like the people are behind you can
do this thing like the machinery on this
side
is stronger than it is on the other side
yes uh and that was one of my big
learnings i'm now
still by the way grinding to try and uh
find ways around the machine to up and
the machine
i think the forward party is a real
historic opportunity because the
two-party system is so
decrepit and ossified and people aren't
loyal to it um but
uh you know we had to run the campaign
to know what we know
and what's interesting too is like if i
you know it's like like you said it's
like you look back at it and this is not
a story in my mind it's like oh if we
just done that one thing differently or
made this other decision then like you
know i don't know what like yeah like
like that good point like
i don't feel that
no i don't either i don't have any
regrets really because it wouldn't
matter i don't have regrets in that way
either i mean did we make mistakes yes i
mean i made i want to be clear i made
all the mistakes like all of them and if
you want to get a sense of some of
zach's mistakes you should definitely
read long shot there you go um but like
but the the
um the crucial elements in my mind were
not within our control
yeah uh and so it's something that you
know it's like i feel really
uh
proud of and pumped by what we
accomplished um and the question now is
can we continue to build
and adapt and innovate uh and and keep
making awesome things happen for people
and that that is actually the point of
this book the way it closes like
the point of the book is that the game
has changed like we were living proof
that this game is changing yeah no one
thought we could do it the gatekeepers
of power
uh from traditional politics of old like
their structures are cracking they're
not cracked i think they're more cracked
than the republican side but generally
speaking they're cracking not thrown but
they're not done yet but
the trend is going the way you want it
to the trend is going more populous it
is becoming uh more and more likely that
and more and more andrew yangs start
existing and popping up um which is
exciting and i think politics in the
future is gonna look very different
which is uh i hope a good thing there's
some you know it's tough to compromise
when you're a type of
you know i talk about identity brands
it's tough to compromise from your like
you know strong positions on certain
things but over time i'm optimistic on
where this goes and i do think forward
party uh in itself mechanically might be
um one of the things that actually
creates a bigger wedge in some of these
cracks so well i think things are
changing man i think the challenge for
us is really to see it some of those
uh changes be positive as opposed to
some of the negative changes you know i
mean like like some very negative things
are now possible and on the table that's
true and let's get some positive things
that's my goal nowadays i i'm choosing
to be happy man like i'm choosing just
glass half full well you should be very
very happy and proud of this
accomplishment my campaign would never
have reached millions without zach's
leadership and strategies anyone who
wants to make change in the world or who
simply loves an incredible story that
you all made possible so thank you all
so much thank you all of this book
all the staffers and everybody like look
this i'm my name's on the cover but you
know i'm literally getting credit for a
lot of the work
an incredible team did so now you know
how i feel bro
we love you guys we'll see you next week
[Music]
you